well I am woke now and I can prove it
here you go I love illegal immigrants
here's Ricky Jes making some Politically
Incorrect jokes telling the truth for
truth's sake and being funny at the same
time what a novel approach well I am
woke now and I can prove it there you go
I love illegal immigrants yeah suei now
I sometimes I go down to Dover for the
day right and I I look out right I look
look for a boat and I see a dinghy with
about of them and I go over here like
right and I pull them in I pull them in
Shore and I go Women and Children First
they go there are no women and children
just you Lads is it just come on Lads
come on
Lads if I go down there one day and
there's no boat I am absolutely gutted I
don't I just sort of wander into town
and I I stand by the traffic lights and
I wait for a big lorry to pull up right
and I look underneath and there's a lad
sort of clutching like that and I go way
aheed he goes Gary liner's house I go
it's just down
there for those of you not of the
British persuasion Gary liner is a
former football player who became an
analyst and then he was sort of into the
whole illegal immigration thing anyway
doesn't matter the point is Rick eer Bay
probably or Netflix in and of itself
would not have aired that sort of thing
five years ago that's the exact type of
thing that 5 years ago would have been
cancelled on Netflix if it had even made
it to Netflix in the first place but
what is happening in the world right now
well thanks to the Internet thanks to
online news shows where we're able to
share the truth to you enough people are
waking up not only to the BS from the
Hollywood Elite and their constant
lecturing and hanging of you but to the
reality on the
ground